Salut ! Aujourd'hui on est mardi, mais je sais que quand vous regarderez la vidéo on sera lundi, et le lundi c'est le jour de Vlog.
Aujourd'hui je vais jouer à "L'Underground Comedy Club" au Sentier des Halles.
Je vais là-bas avec d'autres humoristes pour tester les sketchs, etc.
Je vous emmène avec moi !
[musique]
[brouhaha]
Salut !
Ah regarde tu peux brûler comme ça.
Tu vas bien ? Ca roule ?
[musique]
[brouhaha]
Tu vois Laurent, c'est l'image qu'on me donne en fait dans les coulisses on parle de foot.
-Ouais, et puis alors là on parle du bon foot !
Hatem Ben Arfa OCN Nice !
-C parle de foot. Désolé ce n'est pas non plus le truc le plus...
-Moi je prendrai Gignac.
-Ouais.
Saches qu'à la fin de ton sketch, tu vas t'interviewer, te poser une ou deux questions.
-D'accord.
-Mais je suppose que tu les connais déjà.
-C'est moi qui les ai écrites donc tout à fait !
[rires]
-On va essayé de te poser des questions pièges.
-Ah oui, carrément.
-Comme ça si tu peux répondre c'est que tu es vraiment un très très grand mentaliste.
-J'ai des réponses à tout !
[rires]
-Quelle est la couleur du cheval blanc de Henri IV ?
C'est gris parce qu'il s'est roulé dans la poussière !
BAAAM !
BAAM !
-J'avoue, il a réponse à tout !
-Alors attends. Tu me réponds vite ok ?
-Ouais.
T'es dans une course, tu es troisième, tu dépasses le deuxième, t'es combien ?
-Je suis deuxième.
-C'est bien.
-Demande moi mon âge.
-T'as quel âge ?
-33 ans !
BAAAM !
[rires]
-T'es sûr ?
-Et demande moi mon adresse, moi je sais tout.
Je sais tout !
On est hyper bien reçu à "L'Underground Comedy Club".
Je peux te dire qu'on picole...
de ouf !
[rires]
-Sinon, il y a ça.
-Et pourquoi toi tu as ça, et moi j'ai ça ?!
-Ah ! Je ne dis plus rien, apparemment tu travailles trop.
[rires]
[brouhaha]
-C'est drôle cette caméra !
Là ça enregistre ? Non, ça n'enregistre... Ah si ! Ca enregistre !
P*****.
-D'après vous, qu'est-ce que cet homme là fait dans la vie ?
[musique]
[rires]
Hakim, on peut l'applaudir encore !
[applaudissements]
Hakim, on a dit que tu faisais parti du Woop.
-Ouais.
-Ca fait combiend e temps que tu fais parti du Woop ?
-Ca fait deux ans.
-Deux ans.
-Oui, depuis le début, quoi.
[rires]
-Et là tu vois, tout le monde est en train de constater qu'on se marre bien dans les loges...
-C'est ça. C'est vrai en plus !
Ça faisait longtemps qu'on ne s'était pas vu, tu vois, ça fait plaisir.
Ça fait plaisir.
-On se fait des vannes et tout.
-Les humoristes ils sont drôles tout le temps.
Soit dans les loges... Il faut toujours être dans l'amusement, dans le...
-C'est vrai.
-Dans la bonne humeur.
-Ce n'est pas une légende !
-Non, non. C'est toi la légende !
[rires]
Est-ce que tu peux me dire le nom des 10 derniers films que tu as vu, mais rapidement.
Et là tu sais pourquoi ils ne rient pas ?
Parce qu'ils sont tous en train de galérer dans leur tête !
[rires]
On ne peut pas faire ça en fait.
On assaillit d'informations au quotidien, mais on ne peut pas tout retenir, on retient ce qui nous correspond vraiment et ce qui nous appartient.
Le dernier film qu'on a vu, son film préféré, tout ça...
Du coup... Merci Bertrand pour la lumière. Je vais demander à tous ceux qui ont leur films préféré dans leur tête, de lever la main.
Il y a 1/3 de la salle...
Non, non, laisse moi la lumière Bertrand, que je vois tout le monde.
Ok. Oui. D'accord...
Film d'action ?
-Ouais, le porno japonais c'est de l'action...
[rires]
-Ton prénom c'est ?!
-Myriam.
-Myriam. Est-ce que tu peux te lever Myriam ?
Est-ce que tu peux juste tendre le bras, la paume vers le haut, comme ça ?
Il est inscrit dans les lignes de ta main que tu vas me rejoindre sur scène. Voilà, merci Myriam.
[rires]
-Tu peux laisser ta bière quand même, par contre...
Myriam s'il vous plait ! Viens avec moi.
[applaudissements]
[imite Myriam, rires]
Non, mais tu peux baisser la main.
C'était juste pour venir sur scène.
Est-ce que tu peux imaginer un écran de cinéma, juste là, devant toi.
Et projeter mentalement, des images de ton film préféré.
Attention, j'ai besoin vraiment que tu joues le jeu mentalement.
C'est possible ou pas ?
Oui ? Ok.
Imagine le film devant toi. Prends une scène du film, n'importe laquelle dans ta tête.
Si c'est dur de voir des images animées, vois des plans fixes.
Là tu es en train de le faire réellement ?
-Ouais ouais.
-Imagine que c'est devant toi.
Comme si tu regardais, comme si tu détaillais une image.
-Mmmh.
-C'est en noir et blanc ?
-Oui.
-D'accord.
Ok.
[rires]
Continue.
Fixe... D'accord, c'est à l'intérieur. Là t'es à l'intérieur ?
-Non.
-Pourquoi je vois comme une chappe...?
Ah c'est... En fait je vois comme un truc encloisonné...
-C'est une maison...
-D'accord.
Ce n'est pas cohérent l'image d'une prison ? Je me plante alors.
-Ah si ! Si, si, si, c'est dans le film.
[rires]
-Ok...
Une prison.
Film américain ?
-Oui.
-Si c'est en noir et blanc c'est que c'est un film ancien.
Fin des années 80 ?
-Ouais.
-D'accord.
Est-ce que tu peux essayer, de passer les acteurs et les actrices devant toi, devant tes yeux ?
-Ouais.
-Les entendre parler...
etc.
-Ce serait pas un film avec Roberto Benigni ?
-Si.
-Si ? Il joue dedans ? D'accord ok.
Surtout, ce n'est pas des films très connu ça...
Enfin c'est pas très...
[rires]
Vas trouver le titre d'un film qui date fin des années 80...!
Ok.
Est-ce que tu peux aller au tout début du film, que je vois le générique s'afficher ?
Non, ça c'est le prologue, le générique c'est après.
Non je déconne c'est bon.
[rires]
Pour moi c'est un titre de film en 3 mots.
-Oui.
On va tenter le coup.
[rires]
Si c'est ça, c'est un film que j'ai vu.
-Ok.
C'est un film de... de comment il s'appelle... Jim Jarmusch ?
C'est ça ?
-Oui.
-Ton film, c'est, c'est, c'est...
Comme il s'appelle ? [réfléchi]
Ah ça va me revenir !
C'est "Down The Law" ?
-Non.
C'est "Don't By Law".
- "Don't By Law", oh oui !
Merci ! Merci à toi !
[applaudissements]
Merci à vous d'avoir participé au spectacle, c'était un plaisir. Merci beaucoup !
Ciao !
[musique]
-Il y avait une question ?
-Vous êtes mentaliste ?
[rires]
-Oui... Et apparemment hypnotiseur parce que t'as dormi tout le long de mon passage !
Et voilà c'est la fin de ce Vlog. J'espère qu'il vous a plu.
Le Vlog c'est tous les lundis sur la chaine.
Je ne sais pas encore ce que je vais vloguer pour la semaine prochaine.
Demain je suis à "L'Inglorious Comedy Club" de Vérino, si ça vous dit que je vlogue ça, vous pouvez me le dire dans les commentaires.
Si ça vous plait de voir ça, n'oubliez pas de me laisser aussi également un petit...
POUCE EN L'AIR !
Ce matin sur Facebook, je vous ai posé une question pour la vidéo de jeudi. Donc n'hésitez pas à aller sur Facebook pour y répondre.
Comme ça on fait une vidéo, un petit peu ensemble, vous avez compris le principe.
Abonnez vous ! N'oubliez pas que c'est une vidéo par jour pendant un an.
Et rendez-vous demain pour le prochain Mental Vlog.
Ciao !